[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 ce soir je
suis ravie de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle émission nous sommes le
mercredi 10 mai voici le programme de ce
soir la ville de Saint-Cyr-l'École est
sous le choc un concert de rock arien
prenant l'idéologie nazie a réuni
environ 300 personnes dans une salle de
la Maison des Associations Simone Weil
samedi dernier la mère Sonia Bros s'est
dit Bernay et a saisi la procureur de la
République ont fait le point dans
quelques minutes avec notre journaliste
Nicolas dandry - 20% de bénévoles c'est
le constat de la Croix-Rouge des
Yvelines depuis la crise sanitaire une
situation qui devient compliqué pour
l'unité de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
alors qu'aujourd'hui l'inflation
entraîne une hausse du nombre de Béné
certaines épiceries sociales pourraient
fermer leur porte s'il n'y a pas
d'amélioration dans les prochains jours
on en parle avec Denis large tout le
président de la Croix-Rouge de Sky et
Claude wenachter le vice président et
enfin comme chaque mercredi nous
parlerons aussi de cinéma dans votre 7 8
quels sont les films à ne pas manquer
cette semaine au programme Hawaï une
comédie sur un groupe d'amis le
principal un film sur la vie d'un
responsable de collège en banlieue ou
encore l'exorciste du Vatican qui
raconte l'histoire d'un prêtre qui a
réellement existé ce sera enfin
d'émission avec notre journaliste Céline
Charles et je le disais à l'instant
l'unité locale de la Croix-Rouge de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines étant
recherche
urgente de bénévoles certaines épiceries
comme celles d'Élancourt ou de Trappes
risque de fermer son bras supplémentaire
pour en parler avec nous ce soir Denis
largeot je le disais à l'instant vous
êtes le président de la Croix-Rouge de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines bonsoir
bonsoir alors combien est-ce qu'il faut
faudrait de bénévoles pour pour éviter
justement ces fermetures que tout
fonctionne dans les épiceries il nous
faut environ 6 personnes par jour ces
personnes par jour donc pendant cinq
jours vous voyez le 60 personnes ça
c'est pour tout ce que fonctionne très
bien et là actuellement vous avez
combien
une quinzaine une quinzaine donc il faut
faudrait encore
beaucoup de personnes pour nous aider
parce que les comme vous l'avez dit les
bénéficiaires sont là et ils sont de
plus en plus nombreux donc ils ont
besoin de nous et nos contrats avec vous
dans quelques instants nous serons aussi
du coup avec Claude Wayne acheteur le
vice-président de la Croix-Rouge de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines avec nous
également un plateau Maxime Lucas
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes chargés
de la promotion de la vie sportive pour
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines avec vous on
va aussi parler de bénévolat mais pour
les Jeux Olympiques de Paris 2024 le
territoire de 50 ans en Yvelines va
accueillir plusieurs épreuves olympiques
le cyclisme sur piste le VTT le golf
encore le BMX quels sont les besoins en
termes de bénévoles sur du territoire
alors il y a deux types de besoins de
bénévoles il y a deux programmes qui
vont qui vont vivre en même temps il y a
le programme de Paris 2024 qui va se
concentrer sur les sites de compétition
Paris 2024 à lancer son programme de
recrutement et de l'autre côté en
parallèle il va y avoir un programme
lancé par l'agglomération et ce
programme va avoir pour objectif de de
recruter des bénévoles pour l'émission
qui seront de la responsabilité de
l'agglomération à savoir l'accueil et
l'orientation des spectateurs depuis la
gare depuis les modes de transport
jusqu'au lieu de compétition et sur les
sites de célébration et alors combien de
bénévoles pour pour l'agglomération
environ on est encore dans l'étude des
différents des différents besoins on
sait qu'on aura besoin de plusieurs
centaines de bénévoles et on compte
lancer cette appel à candidature à
partir du 24 juin
on aura aussi l'occasion d'en parler un
peu plus tard dans cette émission sur ce
plateau également Jean-Christophe Tual
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes
conseiller municipal délégué aux
mobilité douce pour les clés sous bois
et une grande date approche pour vous ce
samedi 13 mai c'est la fête des
mobilités dans la commune à quoi faut-il
s'attendre cette année alors cette année
c'est le troisième année qu'on réalise
cette fête des mobilités et en fait on
va explorer les différentes facettes de
la mobilité au travers différents
ateliers d'associations de partenaires
que ça soit des edpm des de la will donc
la gyropode on va explorer aussi la
sécurité
et on va s'amuser aussi avec des vélos
rigolos voilà tout pour la famille
passer un bon moment ensemble et
dialoguer échanger sur l'évolution de
notre façon de se déplacer donc un
programme chargé avec de nombreuses
activités on aura le temps d'en parler
aussi dans quelques instants et enfin
avec nous un journaliste de la rédaction
de TV 7 8 Nicolas dandry bonsoir avec
vous on verra dans quelques instants les
informations du jour à retenir dans les
Yvelines mais avant je vous propose de
jeter un coup d'oeil à la météo de
demain
[Musique]
demain matin pas de pluie sur les
Yvelines selon Météo France le ciel
devrait être dégagé au niveau des
températures il fera 9 degrés à
Rambouillet 10 degrés à Houdan et
Versailles et 11 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie dans l'après-midi le
temps devrait se gâter prévoyez quelques
averses pour le restant de la journée
sur l'ensemble du département côté
température il fera en moyenne 15 à 16
degrés et demain nous fêterons la sainte
Estelle le point maintenant sur les
informations du jour à retenir dans les
Yvelines
et donc c'est avec vous Nicolas dandry
on commence par une information révélée
par nos confrères de Mediapart et qui
concerne la ville de Saint-Cyr-l'École
effectivement Mathilde un concert de je
cite rocariens ce serait tenu dans une
salle municipale de la commune
yvelinoise samedi 6 mai à la suite du
défilé dans les rues de la capitale une
soirée musicale avec sur scène trois
groupes néo-nazis ça s'est passé dans la
Maison des Associations Simone Veil du
nom de l'ancienne ministre rescapé de la
Shoah la mairie indique sur Twitter
avoir été trompé par une réservation
pour un anniversaire et on écoute tout
de suite la mère de la ville Sonia Braud
[Musique]
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
d'abord c'est une salle des fêtes ce
n'est pas une salle de concert qui est
louée à des Saint-Cyriens et à des
extérieurs lorsque la personne se
présente on lui fait environ un dossier
et la personne déclare ce pourquoi elle
souhaite louer la salle là en
l'occurrence nous avions à faire un
individu qui souhaitait fêter son
anniversaire ce qui nous arrive assez
régulièrement donc la salle elle a été
louée pour fêter l'anniversaire d'un
particulier samedi soir
[Musique]
je la prends le lundi soir donc le 8 mai
au soir par des confrères à vous
journalistes parce qu'en réalité rien
n'avait chuté jusque là c'est que même
des personnes qui habitent aux alentours
n'ont pas manifesté de difficultés sur
du tapage sur une gêne particulière au
niveau de la salle des fêtes
[Musique]
j'ai décidé de mener une action de
justice avec les images qui moi m'avait
été envoyé par la presse donc ce ne sont
pas des images que nous avons prises et
donc pour donner l'ensemble des éléments
au procureur de la République qui lui
aura la possibilité de faire une enquête
ce qui n'est ni notre cas ni n'aurait
été possible dans une dans le cadre
d'une plainte faite dans un commissariat
il y a un phénomène très simple c'est à
l'école est une ville de deuxième
couronne sur laquelle vous avez une gare
qui est très bien desservie il me semble
que la manifestation s'arrive t'es pas
loin de Montparnasse et mon Parnasse
Saint-Cyr c'est 23 minutes en train je
pense le hasard fait que ils arrivent
dans un bâtiment qui a été inauguré au
mois de janvier et qui s'appelle Simone
Veil mais je pense que le premier de
leurs critères c'était cette proximité
[Musique]
il faut noter aussi que Sonia Bro a reçu
plusieurs soutiens d'abord le soutien de
Philippe Benassaya ancien député de la
onzième circonscription des Yvelines et
aussi conseiller départemental dans le
canton de la commune de Saint-Cyr et
puis elle a reçu aussi le soutien de
William Martinez l'actuel député de la
nupes de la 11e circonscription des
Yvelines qui a interpellé le ministère
le ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald
Darmanin ils sont partis de Paris et du
coup on constate bien qu'ils sont
déplacés qui sont venus faire leur
soirée dans les Yvelines et là personne
ne les a suivis personne n'était au
courant personne n'a surveillé ces
personnes voilà c'est là qu'on a
vraiment un grave un grave problème et
donc malheureusement pas de retour de du
ministre de l'Intérieur là-dessus et je
pense que c'est révélateur d'une chose
c'est qu'en fait dans notre pays on
sous-estime ce qu'est la menace de
l'extrême droite ce que je vais faire
c'est demander au service de l'État dans
le département que nous en tant qu'élu
nous puissions avoir une réunion
d'information sur l'état de ces
groupuscules d'extrême droite sur le
département et le niveau de la de la
masse et on poursuit ces informations du
jour Nicolas en prenant la direction des
mursaux maintenant ce matin au Mureaux
2,4 tonnes de résine de cannabis ont été
retrouvés dans un immeuble par les
policiers de la Sûreté départementale
des Yvelines trois personnes ont été
interpellées selon nos confrères du
Parisien Aujourd'hui c'est aussi la
journée de commémoration de l'abolition
de l'esclavage à cette occasion une
secrétaire d'État s'est déplacée du côté
de Houilles effectivement il s'agit de
Sonia bac S secrétaire d'État auprès du
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
chargés de la citoyenneté elle s'est
déplacée dans la dernière demeure de
Victor Schoelcher à Houilles Victor
Schoelcher militant pour la fin de
l'esclavage dans les colonies françaises
un combat qu'il a gagné en 1848
lorsqu'il a signé le décret abolissant
l'esclavage le maire actuel de la ville
Julien Chambon a décidé de dédier ce
lieu de mémoire de l'homme politique
situé donc à Houilles une fois ouverte
au public ça demeure viendra rejoindre
la liste des maisons personnages de
personnages illustres des Yvelines que
abrite le département toujours un
politique Nicolas aujourd'hui Jean-Noël
Barrault le ministre délégué au
numérique a présenté un projet de loi un
projet de loi dit de régulation et de
sécurisation de l'espace numérique le
ministre la présenté ce matin en conseil
des ministres objectifs de ce texte
rétablir la confiance des citoyens dans
le numérique grâce à plusieurs mesures
notamment le filtre anti-arnaque des
peines de bannissement de réseaux
sociaux pour des personnes reconnues
coupables de cyber-harcèlement ou encore
le blocage de sites pornographiques ne
vérifions pas l'âge des visiteurs et
vous avez une autre information Nicolas
sur la ligne 18 effectivement alors la
ligne 18 n'est pas que l'ensemble des
chantiers du Grand Paris Express qui
était à l'arrêt ce mercredi 10 mai la
Société du Grand Paris organisé une
journée dédiée à la sécurité des sites
la raison et bien cinq personnes sont
décédées des suites d'un accident dans
le cadre des différents chantiers depuis
2020 le dernier accident mortel date du
6 avril dernier à Gonesse dans le Val
d'Oise cette journée intervient à la
suite de la réunion organisé le 26 avril
dernier sous l'impulsion du ministre du
Travail Olivier du soft de nouvelles
mesures prévention devrait être
dévoilées le 17 mai prochain on continue
ces informations du jour avec du sport
notamment avec les adieux de Victor
wendyama de son club de Nanterre et
ouais
pour le basketteur le géant
viennois vecteur Victor web banniyama le
basketteur originaire du chêné a fait
ses adios publics et au parquet qu'ils
ont vu débuter une soirée avec beaucoup
d'émotions après la victoire ce mardi
soir de son club de Boulogne Levallois
face à Nanterre il a fondu en larmes le
joueur a désormais l'esprit tourné vers
les États-Unis le 16 mai se tiendra la
loterie de la draft NBA qui devrait
définir sa prochaine équipe dans les
grandes équipes nord-américaines
toujours en sport la boxeuse Maëva Maëva
à ma douche à annoncé sa retraite
hier soir sur les réseaux sociaux l'ex
championne IBF des super plumes mais un
terme à sa carrière pour des raisons de
santé dans un long message elle explique
que sa blessure à l'oeil l'interdit de
réaliser de nouveaux combats et l'oblige
à dire adieu à une éventuelle
qualification pour les Jeux Olympiques
de Paris pour laquelle elle s'entraînait
avec la fameuse équipe la team Farrugia
d'Élancourt la boxeuse continue
néanmoins son parcours professionnel
gardienne de la paix à Paris elle a
récemment réussi en mars dernier
l'écrit du concours d'officier de police
et espère un jour intégrer le raid merci
beaucoup Nicolas dandry pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une information ou une
image qui vous a marqué près de chez
vous n'hésitez pas à nous la partager en
utilisant le hashtag 7 8 news
on en parlait en début d'émission
l'unité locale de la Croix-Rouge de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines étant manque
de bénévoles de épiceries solidaires
risquent la fermeture pour en parler
avec nous le président de la Croix-Rouge
de 50 ans en Yvelines Denis largeot et
le vice-président Claude qui nous a
rejoint en plateau bonsoir alors comment
est-ce que vous expliquez aujourd'hui ce
manque de bénévoles
qui sont consécutifs en premier lieu au
covid dans la période du covid on a eu
beaucoup de défections parce que nos
bénévoles sont des gens relativement
âgés ce sont des gens qui sont
principalement à la retraite puisque nos
bénévoles travaillent la semaine donc le
covid nous a
contraint à contraint un certain nombre
de personnes de ne plus accéder à aux
épiceries donc ça c'est la première
raison la deuxième raison c'est que les
choses change et que le bénévolat
maintenant c'est plus du tout comme
avant avant on était on s'engagé et on
s'engageait sur le long terme maintenant
on fait du bénévolat à court terme
c'est une fois par semaine une fois la
semaine et puis trois semaines ou 4
semaines après donc il y a pas de
continuité or nos épiceries et elles
sont ouvertes toute la semaine donc nous
avons besoin de continuité
donc c'est ça la raison la dernière
raison je crois que personne n'a
intuitité cette raison là mais les
problèmes économiques que nous avons
font que beaucoup de grands-parents et
Ben sont contraint de s'occuper de leur
petit enfant parce que les couples n'ont
plus les moyens de avoir une nounou
d'avoir
un certain nombre de choses donc
beaucoup de grands-parents qui étaient
nos bénévoles et bien ne viennent plus
parce que il faut s'occuper des petits
enfants
et alors ne viennent plus ou ne viennent
plus pendant certaines périodes pour
être précis
alors comment fait-on aujourd'hui pour
devenir bénévole à
la coupe
nous avons aussi un site web sur lequel
on peut trouver l'adresse de la de la
Croix-Rouge de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
et ensuite on nous appelle et nous avons
une personne
chargée du recrutement le site web qui
s'affiche juste en bas de votre écran
voilà et donc il y a une personne qui
est dédiée donc recrutement et
on passe un entretien entre guillemets
c'est une prise de contact et après les
les bénévoles peuvent intégrer l'unité
locale pour travailler alors quels sont
justement les différentes missions les
différentes tâches qu'on peut effectuer
si on devient
et d'une des plus grandes unités locales
des Yvelines c'est même la plus grande
donc nous avons une halte répit
Alzheimer nous avons un espace bébé
parents nous avons la maraude Claude en
est la responsable nous avons les
secouristes on est la plus grosse unité
locale avec 50 pas tout à fait 45
secouristes nous avons deux épiceries et
la vestiboutique la vestiboutique nous
avons une domiciliation la domiciliation
à l'heure actuelle nous avons environ
500 personnes domiciliées chez nous ça
veut dire 500 personnes c'est 500
courriers peut-être expliquer ce que
c'est la domiciliation c'est pour les
personnes qui n'ont pas de logement fixe
c'est donner une adresse aux personnes
qui n'ont pas de logement fixe comme
vous dites et donc c'est recevoir le
courrier trier le courrier donner le
courrier ça demande
un nombre de bénévoles importants à
l'heure actuelle nous n'en n'avons pas
assez donc nous ouvrons que le mardi
après-midi pour distribuer le courrier
parce que on reçoit entre 50 et 100
personnes et donc il faut des bras pour
ça pour faire ça vous constatez une
baisse des personnes qui souhaitent
s'engager dans le bénévolat ou du euh
bénévolat par intermittence si on peut
utiliser ce terme du phénomène que vous
avez décrit vous personnellement je vous
pose la question à tous les deux
qu'est-ce qui vous motive encore à vous
engager dans le bénévolat alors vous
êtes Président vous êtes vice-président
mais qu'est-ce qui motive en général les
personnes qui sont à la Croix-Rouge
qu'est-ce qu'il est motivé à s'engager
dans le bénévolat c'est comme Claude ou
moi nous sommes engagés pour aider les
gens on ne sait pas engager pour être
vice-président ou Président on s'est
engagé pour aider les gens vous savez
dans les épiceries nous avons plus de
1000 familles dans les deux épiceries
mille familles si on n'est pas là ces
gens-là ne mangent pas
d'accord et
on me dit si tu as pas assez de
bénévoles tu fermes oui mais que
deviennent les gens que deviennent les
gens qui frappent à la porte de
l'épicerie tous les jours donc si on
tire une conclusion de ce que vous dites
c'est qu'aujourd'hui les gens ne
souhaitent pas aider les gens puissent
ils sont pas motivés à aider les autres
je pense pas je dirais pas ça pour être
en dehors de la polémique non je dirais
que le bénévolat change que les
contraintes sont différentes que le
covid nous a donné un coup de frein
énorme et que la situation économique
fait que les grands-parents qui sont le
nerf de la guerre des bénévoles dans
notre unité locale les grands-parents
s'occupent d'autres choses ben écoute
déjà alors du scandale est-ce que vous
tournez vers le public des jeunes qui
pourraient s'engager dans la sauce on se
tourne vers les jeunes pour le
secouriste les secouristes nous avons
une unité secouriste qui est la plus
grande des Yvelines et ça ce sont des
jeunes des jeunes du travail la semaine
mais qui le week-end et ben font du
bénévolat dans le secouriste et ça
marche très bien par contre pour la
semaine mais ces jeunes là ils sont pas
disponibles alors on utilise beaucoup de
stagiaires donc ce sont des étudiants
maintenant je sais pas si vous le savez
mais dans les universités donc cursus il
y a un cursus demandé de solidarité donc
on a beaucoup d'étudiants qui viennent
faire ces stages chez nous mais le reste
des bénévoles ce sont des gens qui sont
à la retraite et alors Nicolas dandry
vous avez demandé pourquoi Denis largeot
et Claude gwenacheteur était bénévole
souhaité s'engager nous sommes aussi
allés demander aux bénévoles de la
Croix-Rouge pourquoi est-ce qu'il
s'était engagé en écoute en fait moi ce
que je veux c'est aider les gens un
maximum c'est ça qui m'a fait venir à la
Croix-Rouge et la Croix-Rouge en fait
c'est parti de de ma vie en fait
quotidienne parce que la Croix Rouge à
17 principes qui sont aussi mes valeurs
ça fait mal au cœur de voir des gens
quelquefois âgés qui sont dehors ou des
tout jeunes ou des femmes enceintes avec
des enfants franchement c'est ça devrait
pas exister mais c'est important qui est
des gens pour témoigner et puis pour
leur donner un petit peu d'espoir il y a
pas besoin d'avoir un diplôme spécifique
c'est simplement une envie de vouloir
aider les autres
voilà ça c'est très important et venez
nous rencontrer c'est la première chose
qu'on pourrait dire c'est vrai que s'il
y avait plus de monde ça permettrait
quand même un roulement et puis l'espoir
que que les choses avancent alors on
l'entend dans ce micro-trottoir la
Croix-Rouge à cette principe est-ce que
vous pouvez peut-être nous les rappeler
c'est d'abord l'humanité
c'est d'abord
ne pas faire de différence entre les
personnes
être ouvert à tout le monde nous n'avons
pas de restrictions que ce soit de
religion ou d'apparence et voilà enfin
c'est les principes c'est surtout
l'humanité et aider les autres c'est ça
qui nous motive tous les jours le
principe ils sont gravés dans nos
uniformes
créateur tu peux lire
alors s'il arrive à lire
volontariat unité universalité
neutralité et indépendance et bien merci
beaucoup à vous deux d'avoir accepté
notre invitation et donc si vous
souhaitez devenir bénévole vous
trouverez toutes les informations
nécessaires sur le site internet qui
s'affiche une nouvelle fois en bas de
votre écran rendre la musique classique
accessible à tous voilà la mission de
l'apmsq l'association pour la musique à
50 ans en Yvelines invite depuis plus de
20 ans des enfants issus de quartiers
populaires à découvrir des œuvres
symphoniques et cette année encore les
élèves vont produire un opéra au mois de
juillet à Dieu l'étiquette de la musique
classique réservée à une élite le
reportage de NSA benotti et Julien Leroy
ce concert de musique classique à la
Meuse de Trappes n'est pas un concert
comme les autres il est pédagogique 400
élèves majoritairement de quartiers
prioritaires composent le public ils
viennent de plaisir trap ou encore
Villepreux en tout 11 villes de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines participent à
démocratiser la musique classique pour
la plupart de ces enfants c'est la
première fois qu'il voit jouer un
orchestre sur scène une séance comme
aujourd'hui c'est très intéressant parce
que les enfants découvrent la musique
live comme on dit en bon français la
musique vivante avec des vrais
instrumentistes devant eux et quel que
soit la qualité du disque la qualité des
interprètes à la télévision ça ne
remplacera jamais un concert vivant
l’œuvre symphonique choisie le Concerto
pour clarinette de Mozart l'occasion
pour ses élèves de CE2 CM1 d'en
apprendre davantage sur l'histoire de ce
compositeur oui j'ai appris que Mozart
était
célèbre à 6 ans qu'il a composé un
concert
à 11 ans les élèves découvrent aussi les
instruments de l'orchestre on y trouve
la contrebasse la clarinette et une
trompette
le corps bien sûr le basson lui il avait
un son très grave
et par exemple la clarinette avait elle
peut elle pouvait faire le son grave et
du les enjeux pour la pmsq et veiller la
curiosité des enfants et surtout leur
montrer que la musique classique est
partout même les Beatles ont repris la
musique classique il y a plein de choses
il y a des races aussi qui sont sur la
musique classique ont pris Beethoven ou
bac comme instru de base et ça fait
partie d'un cultures donc c'est très
important qu'ils aient cet apport
effectivement à l'école à l'école de la
République française et c'est vraiment
le moment où on fait groupe voilà et ça
c'est important parce que l'an dernier
moi j'avais un groupe classe qui était
pas toujours
très très soudée et ce projet
pédagogique ça nous a maintenu toute
l'année et ça nous a rassemblé et c'est
vrai que voilà on est devenu une équipe
le projet rassembleur prend encore plus
d'ampleur avec un autre événement
proposé par l'association l'opéra des
enfants en scène accompagné d'un
orchestre symphonique près de 350 élèves
de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines s'initie
Auchan depuis le mois de décembre les
enfants travaillent avec la chef de
chœur des écoles sur un opéra détienne
Perruchon Dogora pour la première fois
le chef d'orchestre pierre calmelet va
alors rencontre pour leur donner des
conseils mais d'abord les élèves et
chauffent leur voix
oui oui oui super
[Applaudissements]
le cours peut commencer la tâche est
complexe l'oeuvre musicale est
endogorien une langue inventée par le
compositeur
[Musique]
puis chanter avec d'autres enfants
couper en même temps garder le rythme
toute la musique
au début ça paraît compliqué mais pas
après on s'y fait on y arrive de toute
façon c'est un projet incroyable que
nous fait vivre la pmsq c'est une
opportunité unique de vivre sur une
scène comme ça une scène nationale avec
un orchestre symphonique de chantait des
oeuvres je pense que personne au monde
ne peut rester insensible à ça
l'orchestre symphonique et la troupe de
jeunes chanteurs se produiront au
Théâtre de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le
samedi 1er juillet un spectacle vivant
qui promet d'être riche en émotion
[Musique]
et nous avons été rejoint un plateau par
une nouvelle journaliste de la rédaction
de TV 78 régénéralèges bonsoir bonsoir
alors comme d'habitude le mercredi vous
nous présentez votre chronique et du
Talk aujourd'hui vous nous parlez d'une
association la courte échelle mais avant
on va parler des Jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 un événement attendu dans les
Yvelines et sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ou plusieurs
épreuves se disputeront VTT cyclisme sur
pis BMX ou encore du golf en tant que
collectivité haute l'agglomération avec
l'autorisation de sélectionner 1000
bénévoles pour en parler avec nous
Maxime Lucas chargé de promotion de la
vie sportive à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
alors combien de candidatures de
bénévoles vous avez reçu pour
l'agglomération alors vous avez raison
grâce aux cinq épreuves accueillies sur
le territoire et au cas de sites
olympiques l'agglomération à le statut
de collectivité haute et ce statut nous
a permis de présélectionner 800
personnes
400 hommes et 400 femmes donc on avait
une base de données qui respecter la
mixité et donc pour recruter ces 800
personnes on a 1300 personnes qui se
sont inscrites sur notre plateforme
c'est pour sélectionner ces 800 du coup
on est passé par une phase de test où on
avait contacté le plus de d'associations
du territoire à inscrire leurs
événements récurrents sur l'année et à
nous demander s'ils avaient besoin de
bénévoles donc nous après on contactait
ces 1500 personnes on leur demandait
d'aller tester sur des postes de
bénévoles sur ces événements tests alors
comment ça se passe ces tests alors
c'était sur l'année 2022 ça donc ils
allaient sur des il y avait des courses
de vélo où ils ont été signal à l'heure
ils ont il y a eu des événements
culturels où ils étaient au niveau sur
des postes d'accueil ou d'orientation
des participants suite à ces événements
les organisateurs nous renvoyaient un
questionnaire l'idée c'était pas de
faire une évaluation très précise des
bénévoles mais de s'assurer finalement
de leur fiabilité
s'ils étaient arrivés à l'heure s'ils
avaient respecter les consignes qu'on
leur avait donné et si c'était pas s'ils
étaient pas partis avant la fin de
l'événement
et donc suite à cela nous on contactait
les bénévoles qui avaient respecté leurs
engagements on récupérait des
informations supplémentaires qu'on a pu
après envoyer à Paris 2024 en fin
septembre donc 400 femmes et 400 hommes
quels sont les profils est-ce que ce
sont plutôt des jeunes plutôt des
personnes
âgées alors on a été relativement
agréablement surpris puisqu'on a eu
vraiment de tout type de profils des
étudiants alors il fallait il faut
savoir que Paris 2024 avait mis en place
des critères de sélection à des critères
relativement simples il fallait avoir 18
ans au premier janvier 2024
par les français ou anglais et être
disponible sur la période des Jeux
olympiques ou paralympiques et pas
forcément de manière consécutive et donc
les gens qui répondaient à la terre
était vraiment des étudiants des
personnes actives ou des retraités
qui sont venus des 12 communes de
l'agglomération mais aussi en dehors de
l'agglomération avec un rattachement à
la gloss soit par une activité
associative ou ils étaient salariés
d'une entreprise du territoire et donc
on a été vraiment très agréablement
surpris de voir une multitude de profils
s'inscrire à ce programme elles seront
quand si elles sont vraiment
sélectionnées pour devenir bénévoles
alors là
clôturé les inscriptions sur sa
plateforme nos 800 bénévoles comme tous
ceux qui avaient été présélectionnés par
les différentes collectivités hautes
avaient une quinze jours d'avance pour
s'inscrire et avait un filtre de
première sélection
et ils seront informés comme tous les
autres candidats à partir de fin
septembre s'ils sont retenus ou pas par
parler 2024 mais par contre si on
souhaite toujours devenir bénévole pour
ces Jeux olympiques de Paris 204 il sur
une porte ouverte puisqu'en juin vous
lancez un nouveau programme pour devenir
bénévole à 50 ans en Yvelines c'est tout
à fait ça il est encore possible d'être
acteur de ces jeux on a tous vu que sur
la billetterie il serait compliqué
d'avoir des places pour pour assister
aux épreuves il reste encore des
possibilités pour pour vivre l'événement
nous l'agglomération on met en place
c'est ça à partir du 24 juin un
programme destiné à recruter des
bénévoles pour les missions qui seront
de la responsabilité de l'agglomération
l'accueil et l'orientation en gare
jusqu'au site de compétition il faut
savoir que les bénévoles qui seront
présents sur ces sites seront les
premières les premiers visages que
verront les spectateurs du monde entier
qui vont se rendre à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines donc 360 000
personnes qui vont venir sur le
territoire et donc les nos bénévoles
seront les premiers visages les premiers
sourires que c'est spectateurs vont
découvrir en arrivant ils ont un rôle
important c'est ça très important et et
vraiment
pour mettre à la rencontre de
spectateurs qui vont venir du monde
entier donc vraiment quelque chose
d'enrichissant donc nous sur ce
programme de recrutement on a une
première phase qui va être de recenser
les les candidatures jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2023 et en candidature un peu
alors on ouvre le plus largement
possible et on table sur quelques
centaines de postes pour voir avec une
priorité donnée aux habitants et aux
acteurs de 50 ans en Yvelines et suite à
cette première phase de recrutement on
va être sur une phase de formation de
ces bénévoles pour qu'il y ait une vraie
plus-value pour les personnes qui seront
à l'intérieur de ce programme et qu'elle
puisse avoir un enrichissement grâce à
cette pratique bénévole donc on a vu
avec Paris 2024 pour avoir tous leurs
contenus de formation à disposition pour
nos bénévoles on s'appuiera aussi sur
des associations du territoire sur de
secourisme sur des petites formations
aux langues étrangères pour accueillir
dans différentes langues les spectateurs
du monde entier
voilà l'idée c'est que les les bénévoles
qui seront présents sur les jeux pour 50
ans en Yvelines puissent avoir toutes
les cartes en main pour pour assurer au
mieux leurs missions et avoir la
meilleure expérience possible
ça vous tente de vous autour du plateau
de devenir bénévole pour les Olympiques
à 50 ans en Yvelines
on peut poser des questions
et peut-être interviewer les bénévoles
qui assurent ces missions autour ou à
l'intérieur des sites olympiques à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et justement
est-ce que est-ce que ces personnes là
qui vont qui vont candidater en juin
sauront sur quel lieu elles vont pouvoir
être bénévoles ou ce sera un peu du
hasard
alors l'idée c'est de voir avec les
personnes qui s'inscrivent là où elles
souhaitent être bénévole
ça sera forcément sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et sur deux
missions bien distinctes la première on
l'a vu c'est laquelle orientation entre
les gares et les sites de compétition
puisque les sites de compétition après
relève de la responsabilité de Paris
2024 et le deuxième
site sur laquelle les bénévoles pourront
interagir c'est sur la ce grand espace
de célébration qui qui va prendre place
au coeur du territoire et donc là on
sera sur un village olympique une fan
zone on sait pas encore quel
dénomination favora mais là il y aura
besoin de bénévoles pour animer cet
espace et faire que tout se déroule pour
le mieux et que ça soit un super site on
puisse vivre les jeux pendant la
quinzaine olympique quelles sont les
pistes des lieux évoqués si vous pouvez
le dire je sais pas mais les pistes des
lieux évoqués pour accueillir ce village
olympique sera ouvert finalement à
l'ensemble du public alors on peut le
dire ce site il vivra au milieu des
sites olympiques il sera sur l'île de
loisirs à proximité immédiate du vélo
Drôme et du stade de BMX et à proximité
aussi immédiate de la colline
d'Élancourt ou se déroulons les épreuves
de VTT
l'idée c'est d'avoir un grand site où on
ne fait pas que regarder les jeux mais
on pourra aussi s'initier à plein de
pratiques sportives on veut que ça soit
un lieu culturel où il y a des des des
concerts on est vraiment dans la dans la
création de cet espace mais on le veut
très ambitieux on veut que tous les 5
continents puissent vivre les jeux et
puis cette présence sur cet espace on
veut que les spectateurs du monde entier
se disent ah mais 50 ans en usine c'est
super je vais y rester un peu plus
longtemps que prévu je vais pas juste
aller au Vélodrome mais je vais rester
sur la Fan Zone et donc donc ça va être
un super équipement pour vivre les
autres
nous on a hâte de vivre ces Jeux
Olympiques à Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
merci Lucas d'avoir répondu à notre
question je le rappelle vous êtes
chargés de promotion de la vie sportive
pour 50 ans en Yvelines sans transition
on va parler d'un tout autre sujet à
présent selon une enquête récente de
l'entreprise drivalia 45% des Français
souhaitent réduire l'utilisation de leur
véhicule notamment pour se tourner vers
des mobilités des mobilités plus douces
aux Clayes-sous-Bois on va fêter une
nouvelle fois ces modes de déplacement
la fête des mobilités se déroule ce
samedi 13 mai c'est de 10h30 à 17h30
dans la cour de l'école Henri pro de
nombreuses animations sont au programme
on en parle avec Jean-Christophe Tual
conseiller municipal délégué aux
mobilité douce aux Clayes-sous-Bois
alors Jean-Christophe fuel quelles sont
les objectifs de cette fête des
mobilités
alors l'objectif principal c'est de
sensibiliser les personnes au mode de
déplacement durable donc mobilité douce
d'une manière ludique et conviviale
voilà donc
comme j'ai dit alors il y a différents
partenaires et autour de ces partenaires
il y aura des il y aura des activités et
donc qui vont tourner autour de la
sécurité de la construction avec des
push car et il y aura aussi une partie
du Bic justement
j'ai lancé le mot pour pouvoir attendre
la question en fait
alors le pouchka c'est c'est quelque
chose qui me tient à cœur en fait c'est
c'est un moyen de mobilité mais ludique
c'est pas voilà c'est c'est on s'amuse
avec mais je pense qu'on apprend
beaucoup avec on apprend beaucoup dans
la construction et je pense que
dans je vais faire un parallèle entre
l'écriture et la lecture quand on
apprend à quand on apprend à écrire
après ça nous ouvre des portes
dans la vie et construire quelque chose
de ses mains avec sa famille avec des
amis ça nous ouvre des portes sur le
futur et donc c'est pour ça que cette
année en a mis en place une course de
Pushka
voilà c'est
le même principe que les caisses à savon
parce que la caisse à savon a des à des
contraintes de freinage parce que faut
bien il faut bien qu'elle s'arrête et
nous on a remplacé la gravité par par
quelqu'un qui pousse d'accord tout
simplement voilà et ça
la sécurité grâce à la MGEN la fondation
de la route qui vont expliquer un petit
peu en fait les règles de sécurité pour
les jeunes et des moins jeunes le casque
les catabiops l'éclairage il y aura un
circuit justement d'initiation entre
un carrefour en feu rouge le stop ce
qu'on faisait à une époque quand je
pense si vous avez commis ça mais moi
j'ai connu ça donc il y a quelques temps
dans les cours
et donc là voilà on le remet en oeuvre
donc ça prend pas mal de choses
il y aura aussi les vélos rigolos
donc les billets rigolos c'est comme son
indique c'est pour apprendre c'est pour
parce que le vélo c'est c'est faut pas
que ce soit une contrainte il faut que
ça soit aussi un plaisir et dans les
vélos rigolos il y a il y a donc il y a
un partenaire qui a qui a récolté tous
les vélos qui trou les plus bizarres
possible et qui les mettent à
disposition et on peut les essayer donc
en fait par exemple alors il y a le
grand bi donc moi je suis fan du Grand
bid déjà après il y a des vélos où
lorsqu'on lui guidon à droite et le vélo
va à gauche donc je vous défie de faire
plus de 2 mètres
après il y a plein de vélos mais je peux
pas être énumérer comme ça il y en a
plein voilà donc il est il les invente
il les fabrique il les récupère dans des
fois et il aimait voilà il est loups et
c'est on passe un très bon moment
ensemble
donc en fait il y a donc il y a tout ce
qui est mobilité il y a aussi les edpm
je sais pas si vous connaissez engin
déplacement personnel motorisé qui vont
nous faire une petite démonstration en
fait les edpm englobe les vélos
électriques
motorisé donc tout ce qui était avant
musculaire est devenu motorisé entre les
trottinettes les vélos et il y a des
nouveaux engins les gyropodes je sais
pas si vous connaissez voilà des espèces
de skate qui avancent tous
ça c'est électrique
debout sur entre entre la roue en fait
de savoir
et donc en fait donc comme toute
nouveauté il y a des gens qui expliquent
qui exploitent
le fond c'est une nouvelle technologie
et ils vont nous faire une petite
démonstration de polo will donc en fait
polo c'est le cheval avec et ben on a
remplacé le cheval par la Giro les
gyropode et il va y avoir aussi une
petite jeune femme qui s'est mise à
faire de la danse sur une roue donc
voilà donc on exploite on explore un
petit peu tout ça
qu'est-ce qui va y avoir quoi c'est
important pour la ville des
Clayes-sous-Bois de faire cette fête des
mobilités alors comme je l'ai dit c'est
je pense qu'il faut il faut tenir au
courant
des
comment s'appelle la mobilité évolue
mais à une vitesse grand V en fait donc
en fait depuis le covid ont rien on s'y
remet en question sur le mode de
déplacement sur sur la pollution sur
plein de choses et je pense que la
les gens sont en attente justement de
tester
passer un moment et de voir un petit peu
comment on va se déplacer comment on va
faire son marché
moi je connais des gens qui qui
n'utilisent plus leur vélo pour faire
les courses ils y vont carriole voilà
donc en fait il y a toute cette et je
pense que rien ne vaut une bonne journée
de convivialité pour discuter de tout ça
et de voir de toucher et de parler avec
ses passionnés là voilà donc
l'association qui va être là sera là
pour expliquer un petit peu déjà le mode
de fonctionnement et pourquoi pas faire
quelques petits baptêmes et on aura
aussi un
comment s'appelle qui dit vélo dit
réparation donc en fait on a on a mis en
place comment c'est de plus en plus en
vogue d'apprendre aux personnes à
réparer eux-mêmes l'atelier de
participatif donc justement on le
faisait dans la ville on se déplaçait
entre
l'association donc en fait on s'est
mutualisé entre plaisir en transition et
lcbt donc les clés se boit
les villes preux en transition et on a
ouvert un local il est pas encore vu
officiellement mais il est presque prêt
et donc en fait on aura un local où les
gens vont pouvoir venir apprendre à
réparer des vélos donc vous avez un vélo
on répare pas la place mais on explique
voilà donc c'est ça le plus important
c'est donc c'est je pense qu'on va créer
une émulation et après bénévoles vont
nous aider à réparer aussi et si on peut
c'est pour moi c'est important voilà
Christophe tu aimes d'avoir accepté
notre invitation donc si vous êtes
intéressé la fête des mobilités c'est ce
samedi 13 mai rendez-vous de 10h30 à
17h30 dans la cour de l'école Henri
c'est l'heure de la chronique et du tal
que Regina ralege ce soir vous nous
parlez d'une association la courte
échelle cette association lutte contre
le décrochage universitaire pour les
étudiants en droit oui Mathilde et cette
association elle est d'ailleurs récente
a été créé l'année dernière par Youssef
bad qui est le premier vice-président
adjoint au tribunal judiciaire de
Bobigny et cette association est là pour
objectif de mettre en relation des
professionnels du droit avec des
étudiants alors ça fonctionne grâce à un
système de parrainage pour que
l'étudiant puisse bénéficier de soutien
et de conseils pendant sa scolarité et
le deuxième objectif de l'association
c'est aussi d'aider ces derniers à
trouver des stages et dans les Yvelines
notamment une convention a été signée
avec la cour d'appel de Versailles qui
s'engage désormais accueillir un à deux
étudiants chaque année alors comment
faire pour être aidé par cette
association alors il y a pas vraiment de
pré-requis pour entrer dans cette
association par contre il faut tout de
même être à partir de la deuxième année
d'études de droit il n'y a pas non plus
d'exigence sur l'école donc l'étudiant
peut tout aussi bien être issue d'un IUT
ou d'une fac par exemple et puis pour
boucler la boucle j'ai envie de dire pas
de limitation géographique non plus
puisque l'association reçoit des de
partout en France métropolitaine mais
aussi de des départements et des régions
d'outre-mer alors ce qui est aussi
intéressant c'est cette volonté de
Youssef bad qui est d'aider les
étudiants c'est un peu finalement comme
un exutoire pour lui puisqu'il a
rencontré énormément de difficultés pour
aller au bout de ses études et vous êtes
justement parti à sa rencontre régime je
vous propose de l'écouter si moi je le
faisais pas si vous voulez c'était
c'était quasiment anormal en fait pour
deux raisons la première c'est que je
suis passé à un cheveu de l'abandon
universitaire en aujourd'hui ce qu'on
appelle la L3 à l'époque ça plaît la
licence j'ai abandonné mes études là
pendant deux ans parce que j'ai dû
travailler à côté et ça n'est que par
l'intervention d'un professeur que
j'avais eu tout au début et qui
connaissait mes compétences en tout cas
de ce qui me disait et qui m'a mobilisé
avec certains membres de ma famille pour
reprendre mes études sans ça je l'aurais
jamais fait et je le regretterai
aujourd'hui sûrement amèrement et la
deuxième c'est un constat très simple
c'est que je n'ai jamais décroché le
moindre stage lorsque j'étais étudiant
j'ai envoyé des centaines de CV je n'ai
jamais obtenu une seule réponse je pense
qu'à plusieurs raisons à ça mais
aujourd'hui moi je me suis dit je suis
arrivé je suis magistrat si moi je fais
pas ça qui le fera en fait
et donc comme on a pu l'entendre les
difficultés sont bien présentes dans
cette filière et d'ailleurs si on
s'attarde sur les chiffres du ministère
de l'enseignement supérieur en première
année de licence et plus de la moitié
des élèves qui échouent aux examens 54%
pour être plus précis sur l'année 2020
2021 ce sont des chiffres conséquents
effectivement régime et est-ce que vous
avez pu échanger du coup avec des
bénéficiaires de cette association oui
Mathilde j'ai rencontré syderia Dramé
donc elle est en stage à la cour d'appel
de Versailles j'ai également rencontré
Robin muratiol qui est chef de cabinet
et qui est en contact direct avec
l'association la courte échelle je vous
propose de les écouter je trouve que
c'est ma réelle opportunité et je trouve
ça vraiment incroyable qui est tout ce
dispositif autour pour pour vraiment
aider des
étudiants en droit à trouver des stages
parce que c'est nécessaire à notre
formation c'est assez difficile parce
que c'est soit on doit passer par notre
réseau personnel
pour la plupart des étudiants ils l'ont
pas ou on doit déposer les candidatures
mais le souci avec ma formation c'est
que ces formations qui
n'est pas très connu du milieu juridique
des effets
entre guillemets on va dire que des
élèves de licence sont beaucoup plus les
élèves issus de licence sont beaucoup
plus
facilement recrutés on est très content
de notre expérience et on souhaite
absolument la renouveler et c'est vrai
que
j'allais dire dans le droit on a bien
sûr les étudiants les filières
universitaires un peu classiques mais
aussi des filières plus
professionnalisant comme comme les IUT
et là encore eux aussi pour nous c'est
un enrichissement parce que c'était de
ces étudiants qu'on accueillait pas
parce que ça se présentait pas on
accueillait pas ces étudiants avant et
là encore une fois depuis l'année
dernière on est très contents ça nous
fait aussi une ouverture pour nous et
encore une fois on est aussi très
sensibilisé au volley dimension sociale
ascenseur social pour être plus précis
voilà alors l'association est très
active aujourd'hui en un an c'est plus
de 2000 demandes de stage qui sont
traitées et plus de 270 parrainages
partout en France merci beaucoup Régine
ralege pour toutes ces informations et
si vous êtes intéressé vous trouverez
plus d'informations sur le site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de votre écran
allez c'est l'heure de parler de cinéma
à présent dans votre 7 8
et on commence avec le coup de coeur
Ciney d'un professionnel du 7e art ce
soir c'est le réalisateur yvelinois
Gauthier Bara qui nous partage son coup
de cœur pour le film le professionnel on
replonge dans les années 80 avec
Jean-Paul Belmondo regardez
[Musique]
bonjour je vais vous parler du film le
professionnel de George Lautner qui est
sorti le 21 octobre
1980 il est pour ma part l'un des
meilleurs films avec notre cher acteur
Jean-Paul Belmondo il a été très
critiqué pour le côté raciste du film et
également la caricature de la tournure
du scénario et pourtant il a eu son
fameux succès avec une apparition de
Robert Hossein fabuleuse ce film raconte
tout simplement l'histoire de Joss
Beaumont qui est
issu de l'élite de l'armée française il
est chargé d'exécuter le président de la
malagawi un contre ordre va tomber et
pour éviter de nuire au président parce
que ce fameux président est devenu un
ami d'État ils vont incarcéré gosse
Beaumont et lui-même va décider de
contre-attaquer et de réagir
différemment face à l'état français la
manière et son approche est hyper
intéressante ce qui fait vraiment tout
le film nous sommes également bercer
tout le long du film par une musique
d'Ennio Morricone très connue qui est
Chimène et qui apporte une force
mémorable à la chute du film qui est
également noirble et kiffe donne toute
cette puissance au film et à cette
réalisation je pense que là on peut
vraiment parler d'une ligne rouge qui
découle sur une chute puissante
émotionnelle et d'une beauté en fait
pure une réponse et un retour un envoyé
cette musique donne également tout ce
sens pour moi à ce coup de coeur et je
vous laisse sur ces quelques notes de
musique
[Musique]
on poursuit cette page cinéma avec les
sorties à ne pas manquer cette semaine
c'est avec vous c'est une charte bonsoir
bonsoir alors ce soir on prend la
direction d'Hawaï avec un groupe d'amis
faut-il tout se dire entre amis c'est la
question qui se pose dans le film Hawaii
de Mélissa dryjar une bande d'amis de
longue date se rendent comme chaque
année sur l'île pour les vacances mais
cette fois-ci l'ambiance est
sensiblement différente puisqu'une
alerte au missile balistique va être
donné c'est d'ailleurs une fiction tirée
d'une histoire vraie en 2018 une fausse
alerte homicile a été donnée ah Hawaii
alors persuadé qu'ils vont mourir les
langues des amis se délit il s'avoue
absolument tout ce qu'ils se sont cachés
pendant plusieurs années drama assuré
regardez
c'est la femme de notre pâte mais on
t'aime pas tu viens de ce que tu me
faisais avec la crème chantilly
moi je suis une faux cul tout le monde
mais c'était une fausse alerte
elle démarre bien les vacances
bon alors après toutes ces révélations
compliquées de continuer les vacances
comme si de rien n'était et pourtant il
va bien le falloir le séjour ne fait que
commencer un film sur l'amitié la vérité
et ses limites dans lequel on retrouve
par exemple Bérénice Bejo Manu Payet ou
encore Nicolas Duvauchelle vous nous
proposez un autre rendez-vous Céline
avec le principal de Tchad chez Nouga et
oui le film nous plonge dans l'histoire
de Sabri principal adjoint d'un collège
de quartier enfant d'immigrés il a
gravit les échelons de l'éducation
nationale plutôt rapidement et connu
pour sa droiture et ça justesse au sein
du collège pour échapper à la banlieue
dans lequel il a grandi nos jours que
par le travail et sa prête même à
remplacer Estelle la principale très
exigeant et strictes il rêve du même
destin pour son fils Naël qui va bientôt
passer le brevet bien que plutôt doué en
classe ça brille va tout de même lui
donner un coup de main qui pourrait bien
briser sa carrière regardez
bon anniversaire mon chéri
vous pouvez venir s'il vous plaît
qu'est-ce qui se passe avec Maëlle
qu'est-ce que tu as fait
comment vous expliquer tant de
similitudes entre le corrigé type et la
copie de votre fils
vous avez quelque chose à me dire ça
brille
[Musique]
un film qui aborde des thèmes comme la
méritocratie ou le transfuge de classe
et on termine votre sélection Céline
avec un film d'horreur l'exorciste du
Vatican oui alors avec un titre pareil
on sait déjà à quoi s'attendre visage
possédé James cars scène horrifique
d'ailleurs je ne sais pas si vous le
savez mais le Vatican a ses propres
prête est prêtre exorciste c'est un peu
compliqué à dire et le film est inspiré
des véritables archives du Père Gabriel
morph l'exorciste le plus connu du
Vatican ces Russell croc qui l'incarnent
dans le film le prêtre est envoyé en
Espagne ou un jeune un jeune garçon
semble être possédé ces recherches vont
le mener à percer une conspiration liée
à l'Inquisition c'est une bonne série B
dans laquelle on peut voir un ruisselle
croûte rouler en Vespa dans les rues de
Rome un film d'horreur vous l'aurez
compris mais également avec beaucoup
d'humour décalé un film vous le savez
c'est tout ce que vous aimez Mathilde
mais par contre petite sélection parmi
la sélection est-ce que vous avez une
préférence non
le principal pourquoi pas le principal
Céline vous votre préférence moi je
pense que je me tournerai pour une fois
vers la comédie avec Hawaii
Nicolas d'André vous nous avez une
dernière information à vous partager on
vient de m'apprendre à l'instant Gérald
Darmanin le ministre de l'Intérieur est
actuellement aux Mureaux suite à la
saisie de 2,4 tonnes de résine de
cannabis il est en compagnie du député
de la circonscription de la 12e
circonscription des Yvelines car l'olive
et du maire de la ville François Garet
alors le ministre de l'Intérieur s'est
déplacé parce qu'il semblerait il l'a
déclaré que c'est la saisie quasiment la
plus record de ces 30 dernières années
on parle de la valeur marchande de 20
millions d'euros en termes de valeur
marchande autour de cette de cette
saisine de drogue bon on va en savoir
plus dans les prochaines heures le
ministre de l'Intérieur donc
actuellement au Mureaux suite à cette
saisine record de drogue par la police
de la sûreté départementale des Yvelines
et bon affaire à suivre on détaillera
cette information sûrement dans le 7 8
de ce jeudi on continuera de vous
informer bien évidemment à travers nos
programmes et sur nos réseaux sociaux
c'est bientôt la fin de ce 7 8 mais
avant jetons un coup d'oeil à la météo
de demain
demain matin pas de pluie sur les
Yvelines selon Météo France le ciel
devrait être dégagé au niveau des
températures il fera 9 degrés à
Rambouillet 10 degrés à Houdan et
Versailles et 11 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie dans l'après-midi le
temps devrait se gâter prévoyait
quelques averses pour le restant de la
journée sur l'ensemble du département
côté température il fera en moyenne 15 à
16 degrés et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci pour votre fidélité je
vous souhaite une belle soirée sur TV 78
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]